dramatic video captured by a snowboarder
reveals what it's like to be swept up in
an avalanche the snowboarders helmet
camera was recording when the snow
suddenly surrounded him in the French
Alps last week his safety equipment
saves his life so far this year 16
people have died in similar accidents
across the western US in [ __ ] Valley
California rescuers quickly dug out this
man after he was buried in an avalanche
at North America's largest ski resort
Whistler Blackcomb in British Columbia
the Ski Patrol uses a variety of tools
including helicopters and explosives to
try and keep everyone safe Carter Evans
went to the slopes and flew over the
mountains with the life-saving team
looking for clearance for two sleds from
the valleys the Alpine on the route it's
6 a.m. at the base of Whistler mountain
and avalanche forecaster Anton Horvath
and his dog Zeus head up hill to start
their day
today we were shooting gun one our
targets are all along the ridge here the
ridge line and upper Frances cliffs
recent snowstorms have filled the
mountains many avalanche prone areas
with unstable snow we've got over 200
slide paths on Whistler mountain alone
so after a storm cycle takes at least a
couple hours to get everything open once
the Avalanche around leaves the gun and
it's in midair then it became our mitts
elf and that detonates on impact how
serious of a threat our Avalanche is
here they can be a serious threat but I
mean that's part of our main job here is
being able to mitigate any kind of
serious Avalanche hazard as a supervisor
with Whistler Ski Patrol Tracey Morrison
and her team of 60 use a variety of
methods to keep unstable snow from
dangerously building up and breaking
loose
but before they deploy any of those
tools it all starts with science we'll
just do a little dig and we'll kind of
punch at it to sort of see what kind of
resistance it has you're checking those
different layers and yeah and does the
the different types of layer does that
indicate a slide is more likely in
certain circumstances it's my magnifying
glass we're looking at layers like the
doctors kids for snow analysis yeah
pretty much
Horvath has been monitoring this roped
off plot of what's known as snow study
terrain all season see that there oh
yeah but the fact that it broke apart
when you were tapping on it I saw some
weakness that means that there's
potential for a slab avalanches where it
could just slide like yeah exactly
and that looks like this the devastating
combination of gravity and snow that is
every ski resorts worst nightmare
so when avalanche conditions form snow
science turns to preventive action
does that mean you hit him harder with
the larger explosive yeah will hit it
harder they hit the snowpack with these
explosives made out of PETN Orpen
thright each with the explosive force of
a stick of dynamite
we have many guests to come here want to
ski in avalanche terrain Doug McFarland
oversees all operations at Whistler
mountain and that includes the many
facets of Avalanche control we have a
lot of avalanche terrain that rolls into
our designated ski runs or groomed
passes you pick out a slide in that
terrain to people skiing below you
you're creating a hazard to that skier
below so we go on and do effective
avalanche control prior to you going
there if the terrain is tricky where the
patrol teams have to navigate or we'll
use a helicopter to actually make the
whole thing go faster
[Music]
what you can do is you can get surgical
with the helicopter you can get that
shot exactly where you want it rich line
up by the top of whisper mount their
large overhanging features fitted by the
width of the top of these ridge lines
and wanna knock them down for obvious
reasons this mission flies after the
lifts are closed and skiers are long off
the mountain three out of the helicopter
that will give us about a minute to move
out of the way for the explosion
Oh
tourists patrol on you place your ball
is complete we didn't get much in the
way results at a shot number 1 and 3 but
shot number 2 we got a good solid size 2
results so we're happy with that size -
avalanche was I've to is large enough to
bury or kill a person and that's exactly
the sort of tragedy Whistler Ski Patrol
works sunrise to sunset to prevent for
CBS this morning Carter Evans Whistler
British Columbia it's good to know
they're doing that in the lessons that
they're learning that can help save
lives down the road yeah
can you guys move like that last skier
I'm so fascinated by skiing because I'm
so terrified of it I think it's so
pretty when you see when it's done right
it's pretty yeah when it's done wrong
like me on the magic carpet ride with
the kids it's really I know but I love
that you've taken up a new I do try it's
an inspiration she can up might be
generous but I did